well hello this is different probably
not what you were expecting from the
gist unless you were on my facebook or
my Twitter or my YouTube where I told
you that this was the video I was gonna
be doing this week then you would expect
it and this is not exciting but anyway
for those of you who don't know my name
is Jess MacDonald and this show is the
gist and I'm actually on my own this
week as the GameSpot video team because
the Australian games while video team is
myself and Edie and Edie is still on
holiday so here we are I figured instead
of skipping next week or just doing a
random episode where you wouldn't be
able to see my face because I have no
cameramen I would just shoot this on my
front-facing camera
believe me I tried to get the other side
camera working and it was not happening
for me I'm not a camera woman uh but
here we are and um I have a bunch of
questions that I asked you guys what you
might want to know about the show or
that my purse s so how it comes to be or
anything anything anything and I'm gonna
answer some of them best
we should probably roll the intro so I
will be right back
[Music]
a lot of you guys wanted to see the
space we shoot in the game spot destroy
the office is actually not that big but
um we're in half a floor in the middle
of the city and this is the games room
that we shoot in it is small it is very
small we shoot on to this side of the
room we used to shoot on to the other
side of the room which is where all the
posters are so you might recognize that
as well as for the team that works on
the gist a lot of you guys were
wondering who sort of has their hands in
the pie apart from me and it's me and
Edie basically um I write the gist I
research it I choose the topics and then
this show goes into QA well Lucy James
and Chris what is you probably know of
will have a look at my script and see if
I've said anything stupid and Edie we'll
also have a look at it then Edie will
shoot the show so everything you say
he's behind the camera then ed gives me
the edit I put it all together and I
publish it so you see it on site Bob
Jones asks how long does it take to make
an episode from show idea to end up
editing I usually give myself the week
but of course a lot of you guys would
know that I shoot games but news in the
morning so by the time that I'm done
researching and writing and shooting
that that's when I will dedicate as much
as I can of the rest of my day to the
gist I research for a little while to
figure out what topic would be good for
that week a lot of you guys are
wondering how I choose my topics
basically it's what I cared about that
week what I thought was interesting what
I think you guys might care about I
spent a lot of time thinking about
topics that I would be interested in and
that I can generally see are interesting
to the gaming community at the time and
then I try and pick things like that
palor amistad asked does the jist have
to be a list presentation now a lot of
you guys might remember when it just
wasn't in list form it
sometimes a listen sometimes wasn't so
we decided a few months ago to keep it
in a list form and the main reason for
that was to narrow the show concept and
one of the reasons I was okay with that
is that it actually doesn't stop me from
doing anything I wanted to do some of
the discussion topics that I would do
before like my episode on why the Sims
wasn't so great
or why SimCity wasn't so great I'm sure
I've done episodes on a couple of things
those were kinds of things that I could
fit into a list episode anyway so I
don't think it was a huge blur to the
show I know the list format gets a lot
of crap from a lot of people and I can't
see why I know that it's generally seen
as like cheap easy wins and stuff but I
actually really value the gist on
providing quality content I try really
hard to make sure that everything I put
out is valuable in some way and yes
sometimes it's not going to be super
massive food-for-thought sometimes it's
really hard bosses in dark souls or it's
the worst games of the year but I
personally get a lot out of those as
well so I hope that you do too I think
you do too that said I'd love to hear
what you actually like the main things
that you want to see I'd love to frame
the rest of the things I do this year on
your actual feedback because I try and
gather an idea of what you like because
we have metrics and we have stuff I can
read about the episodes that do well and
the episodes that don't do as well but
nothing is gonna be as valuable as just
hearing you guys say to me directly I
like this or I don't like that James
Cole empanada asks do you collaborate at
all with IDI and Zarine I knew you
bright the episodes but did they help
with the ideas or other pots sometimes I
will have a bunch of weeks where I'm
just like I know what I want to do what
I'm gonna do this and
only if it's a really dumb idea will it
be like no but there are other weeks
where it can be hard to think of
something to do every single week for a
feature show we're over 100 episodes
into the gist now so it can sometimes
get to a point where it's tricky to
think it's nothing to do so there are
weeks where I tend to add I'm like what
am I gonna do yeah and that's why he he
gives me ideas like um like the the year
of the grappling hook
that one was Edie I had another question
that asked why I talk casually like in
the video I made on my youtube channel
the other day and this one and why this
voice is so different from my case my
nice voice and my gist voice and the
answer is um probably I haven't straily
an accent I don't know if you noticed
and some people find it to be a little
thick and a little confusing and I do
have a tendency to mumble Australians is
just not interested in like consonants
well I syllables we just we just skip it
um so especially when I started doing
the news I would enunciate a lot more
and I would try and be clear and
obviously when I have a script I don't
know man ah and that can come off a
little contrived so it's something I'm
working on and I can tell you that so I
think that's more than enough for me
I've been talking for ages um but do let
me know what you think about anything
that I've said or what you want to see
from the gist this year tell me what you
thought of this episode I know it was a
little odd I hope it was okay and I will
be back next week with a regular episode
but let me know what you want to say
because I am NOT gonna be riding it for
a week so perhaps I can work off one of
the ideas you give me in the meantime I
am always contact bull on Twitter where
I'm at just
donal I have a Facebook page and a
YouTube channel if you want to chat to
me there or give me advice or give me
suggestions that'd be awesome
um that I will catch you next week and
thank you so much for watching
you